>> AND THAT'S A CUT ON
REHEARSAL.
LET'S WILL BE READY TO ROLL IN
FIVE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> HOW IS IT GOING,
MR. DIRECTOR?
>> GOOD, GOOD.
I'M REALLY EXCITED.
>> WELL, YOU SHOULD BE WRITING
AND DIRECTING A COMMERCIAL FOR
PEPSI.
IT DOESN'T GET MUCH BIGGER THAN
THAT.
>> OH, HEY.
THIS IS MY SISTER.
I GOT TO GET THIS REAL QUICK.
>> CARRIE, HEY.
SORRY, I CAN'T SUPER TALK RIGHT
NOW.
I'M ON THE SET OF A HUGE PEPSI
COMMERCIAL I'M DOING.
I KNOW, RIGHT?
THIS IS, LIKE, COMPLETELY MY
IDEA, AND NOW, THEY'RE DOING IT.
THAT'S GREAT, YEAH.
I MEAN, OKAY, SO WELL IT'S AN
HOMAGE TO THE RESISTANCE AND FOR
THE HUGE PROTESTS IN THE STREETS
REMINISCENT OF
BLACK LIVES MATTER.
AND SO, EVERYBODY IS MARCHING,
RIGHT?
AND THEY CAN SEE POLICE
OFFICERS, AND THEY THINK IT'S
GONNA GO BAD BECAUSE THERE'S
KIND OF, LIKE, A STANDOFF.
AND THEN, KENDALL JENNER WALKS
IN, AND SHE WALKS UP TO ONE OF
THE POLICE OFFICERS, AND SHE
HANDS HIM A PEPSI.
AND THEN, THAT PEPSI BRINGS
EVERYBODY TOGETHER.
[ SIGHS ]
ISN'T THAT, LIKE, THE BEST AD
EVER?
♪♪♪
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
UH-HUH.
SORT OF TONE DEAF.
>> ALL RIGHT, GUYS!
THREE MINUTES AWAY!
THREE MINUTES!
>> THANK YOU.
>> I THINK MAYBE YOU JUST DON'T
GET IT.
IS DOUG THERE?
CAN YOU PUT HIM ON?
DOUG!
HEY, MAN!
TAKE A BREATH.
WHAT'S UP?
HEY, I WANT TO RUN THIS PEPSI
COMMERCIAL BY YOU THAT I'M DOING
AND MAKE SURE YOU ARE LOVING IT
AS MUCH AS I AM.
UM, COOL, COOL.
THE WHOLE THING IS AN HOMAGE TO
RESISTANCE AND
BLACK LIVES MATTER.
SO, EVERYBODY IS MARCHING IN THE
STREETS, AND THEY COME UP TO THE
POLICE OFFICERS -- YEAH, SILLY
COMMERCIAL.
AND THEN, KENDALL JENNER COMES
UP TO A POLICE OFFICER AND GIVES
HIM A PEPSI, AND EVERYBODY
CELEBRATES.
PEOPLE OF EVERY SINGLE CULTURE
COME TOGE -- UH-HUH.
UH-HUH.
NO, WE'RE CELEBRATING THESE
CULTURES.
WE'RE CELEBRATING BLACK CULTURE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT WE'RE ARE ALSO CELEBRATING
ASIAN CULTURE.
OH.
DO YOU WANT ME PLAYING THE
CELLO?
MM, MM, MM.
OH.
GOT IT.
JUST KIND OF USING THEM?
>> YEAH.
>> IT'S ALL SODA?
[ WHISPERING ]
GREAT.
IT'S GONNA BE BAD.
>> ALL RIGHT, PEOPLE!
60 SECONDS UNTIL WE ROLL ON THIS
MAN, SINGULAR VISION!
>> AH, YES!
>> HEY, MAN, COULD YOU PUT A
NEIGHBOR ON THE PHONE, A BLACK
ONE?
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
HI, MA'AM.
HEY, WE'RE SHOOTING A LITTLE
PEPSI COMMERCIAL OVER HERE.
I WANT TO RUN IT BY YOU, AND GET
YOUR OPINION ON IT.
OKAY, GREAT.
SO, THE WHOLE THING IS AN HOMAGE
ON BLACK LIVES MATTER.
UH-HUH.
DON'T EVEN TOUCH IT?
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
IT WOULD BE INSANE TO TOUCH IT,
RIGHT?
OKAY.
DON'T EVEN SHOW POLICE?
[ SIGHS ]
YEAH.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO IF YOU WERE IN
MY SITUATION?
JUST RUN TO MY CAR?
OKAY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE GOT TO GO, PEOPLE!
>> HEY, KENNY.
DO WE HAVE TIME FOR A REWRITE?
>> HEY, NO CAN DO, BUD.
LET'S INVITE KENDALL TO SET.
SHE HAS HER HEART OUT IN
45 SECONDS.
>> NO, NO!
>> OKAY, WELL I'LL CALL YOU.
I AM ON THE SET OF MY PEPSI
COMMERCIAL.
UM, I STOP THE POLICE FROM
SHOOTING BLACK PEOPLE BY GIVING
THEM A PEPSI.
I KNOW!
IT'S CUTE, RIGHT?
>> UGH!
♪♪♪
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]